普通人就做三件事做的三件事就够了
做什么呢
我今天
我不来航舟吧
就好很多
不要优秀的朋友再一块交流
就玩着刚回来
简单总结一样吧
首先第一个
你一定要做自内体
要做自内体
就是能够
让更多的人看到你
你就会有更多的机会
我把它称之为信任表面起
就你的信任直就会有有有有有有有
因为接受人愿来多
愿意多
愿意多能看到你吧
对吧
好
第二个是什么呢
第二个就是
就是为什麽
因为
哎员能帮你干活
你有想法
哎员就能帮你把他做出来
所以你只需要负责思考
去思考什么东西有用的
对别人有价值的
想到了以后
然后哎员就能帮你做出来
好了
做出来以后
那么
因为有前面的信任表面起
更多人看到
所以你会发现你的做的东西
更有可能给别人带来多
带来价值
我们说的
收入来自于什麽
收入自来自于
这种价值交换
对吧
有用那我就愿意跟你负败
只要你对我有
所以
这个脖子特别简单
你能帮我帐一把
我愿意跟你负败
对吧
就给价值是有无所贵
对不对
所以呢
这是两个
就是这两个
就是我认为普通人
真的是普通
因为你没有别的机会
对吧
你就是
而且这个东西没什麽成本
有成本吗
对吧
你担心什么呢
你没成本
你就是买人的时候
抽出一两个小事
我专门玩玩这个
怎麽喜欢的
说不会
不会可以选
记住了
这句话
不会可以选
如果你先学的不想的学
那根本你你就
老老实说的
就算班
对吧
就做了
这卖时间卖体的就好了
那不订算是什么的
第三个事情就投资
普通人
投资是个非常好的方法
今天
我们刚回来之前
然后有一个朋友问我的
活着你为什么
自己不聪明
听说我聪明要聪明三次
现在我想明白了
我没那么聪明
我不需要再聪明上去
跟别人比
我只干一件事
我专心判断令
我只干什么
每天是好
赚门练一下
住着判断令
判断谁有兵
谁聪明
我把今天投给他
让他帮我赚钱跑吧
对
所以一个位
三个事
第一个事是
这位体积一定要做
让更多的人
看到你
你就可能有更多机会
第二个有AI
你就觉得吃得好
就就想就就观察
看看
做什么东西
就对比较帮助
做到的东西
因为因为有钱
把这种
钱把那种人看
也所以就好像更多成遥
就钱的怎么办
就现在投资
让更专门的人
帮你赚钱